lcp arrive sur youtube en janvier 2020
dans le cadre d'une stratégie de
l'entreprise qui est d'entrer dans le
média global l'arrivée dès le cp sur
youtube
ça permet je pense de dépoussiérer et de
désinstitutionnalisation n est l'entité
[Musique]
c'est le premier résoudre de vidéos au
monde et donc c'est une audience à la
fois jeune et à la fois énorme
bonjour madame lancé pour une émission
pour lcp s'appelle déconfit n'est le
fait d'être sur youtube permet de
contrairement à ce que l'on pense de
pouvoir diffuser les programmes qui sont
plutôt longs et des programmes en avant
première par exemple et pierre basque à
henri iv
parce qu'elle est bonne à l'école les
bons à l'école et donc de ceux assez
parce que c'est un grand lycée lessines
ont apprécié un que c'est surtout la
génération qui réalise les rêves on a
des documentaires quand canton et
documentaires en coproduction et qui est
qu'on souhaite mettre en avant
on a un magazine qui s'appelle les
grands entretiens porté par guy lagache
aujourd'hui à nos jours le programme a
tout de suite très bien marché sur
youtube mais en plus qu'il ya 2
c'est intéressant c'est que xavier neil
a avoué que dans sa jeunesse il avait
travaillé pour la dgse
je suis pas dans les services secrets je
suis un honorable correspondant je sais
pas comment on appelle ça on des
services secrets voilà à qui on dit
régulièrement voilà ce qui se passe dans
notre univers de pirates à cette
information-là a été reprise par un
journal anglais et dès que l'information
a été publiée par ce journal anglais
l'audience a été doublé
[Musique]
on a refait notre site on est plus
présent sur les réseaux sociaux
on est maintenant sur youtube voilà ça
va en tout cas permettre de de
moderniser un peu l'image de la chaîne
et et aussi je pense de rajeunir un peu
le l'audience
[Musique]